MAGGIE JOHNSON:
The way that Google
started was an academic venture.
JEFF DEAN: How do you
find interesting problems
in the world?
ALFRED SPECTOR: Google
depends on academia.
So many of the good ideas
that we've brought forward
to the world come from academe.
JEFF DEAN: One of the real
reasons to engage with academia
is to get a really
fresh perspective.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We
empower academics
to work on real problems.
And in the other direction,
academics bring ideas.
And new approaches then
are put into practice
much more quickly than in
an academic environment.
JEFF DEAN: Oh,
that's interesting,
and that's interesting.
All of a sudden,
you've knitted together
something that is really,
really, tremendously powerful.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We need their
help, because of the problem
we're trying to
solve internally.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Academia can
look far out into the future
and can take greater risks and
look for really interesting
solutions that industry
sometimes cannot.
RANDY SARGENT: My
name is Randy Sargent.
And I am at Carnegie
Mellon University,
where I work on making
large sets of time series
imagery and data explorable
and understandable.
REBECCA MOORE: My
name's Rebecca Moore.
I'm on the Google
Earth and Maps Team.
I'm an engineering
manager there.
I lead the development of
Google Earth Engine, which
is our high
performance computing
platform for environmental
data analysis.
I first met Randy in 2005.
I had just joined the Google
Earth Team as the tech lead
for the Google Earth Layers.
There was an innovative
idea that Brian McClendon
had come up with to overlay
thousands of aerial images
that had been taken by a
National Geographic Explorer
over Africa that were
so high resolution.
They were I think,
one inch per pixel.
If we could succeed in
putting those in Google Earth,
you would be able to
zoom from outer space
to see the eyelashes on a camel.
Randy Sargent was the genius
who figured out how to do that.
So that's where I
first met Randy.
RANDY SARGENT: That
was a fun time.
I was working at
NASA Ames Research
Center with a team of
people at that time.
And we worked with you,
not only on that, but also
on other things, taking
National Geographic stories
and putting them
in Google Earth.
REBECCA MOORE: So from
the very beginning,
going back almost 10 years, it
was all about innovative use
of imagery and making that
accessible to billions
of people who use Google
Earth and Google Maps.
RANDY SARGENT: We were starting
to work with scientists
who wanted to use time
series zoomable images.
So building videos, if you will,
where instead of every frame
being 2 million pixels,
like 1080p video,
each frame might be a
billion pixels or even more.
And we had this
technology, and there
were just a few tiny
applications of it.
And we were looking for
something really interesting
to do with it.
And this is about
the time that I
learn about Earth Engine,
Rebecca's newest project.
And we brainstormed about how
could we connect these two.
REBECCA MOORE: We
built Earth Engine
to store an unprecedented
amount of satellite data.
US taxpayers have
funded missions,
like the Landsat
satellite mission, that
have been continuously
collecting millions of images
of the planet, going back
to the Vietnam War era.
The first project of our
Google Earth Engine Team
was to work with
the US government
to liberate those PetaPixels
of data off those tapes
and bring them online, where
now applying our highly
parallel analysis and
data mining techniques
that we built a framework
for on Earth Engine,
we could start to produce
derivative products.
We'd been tracking what
Randy's-- his project called
Time Machine, which is this
zoomable, panable, explorable,
time-varying imagery.
And he had done one
interesting thing
that related to a
certain satellite
imagery data set, called MODIS.
And we saw that, and
we thought, well,
what if we could connect
his time machine methodology
for this HTML5 video capability
to the PetaPixels of data
that we now had in Earth Engine.
RANDY SARGENT: Before
coming to Google,
the largest video
we had ever produced
was maybe a billion
pixels per frame.
And scaling by three
orders of magnitude
to trillions of pixels
per frame to capture
all of the historical
Landsat, it really
required new ways of thinking
about architecting the software
and interfacing to the large
infrastructure here at Google.
REBECCA MOORE: What
we did with Randy
is build the world's first
interactive, panable, zoomable
animation of the Earth,
going back three decades.
The Earth is
changing dramatically
over these decades in ways
that are observable from space.
You can see urban development,
unbelievable urban development,
not only in what we call
the developing world,
but even in the US.
Las Vegas was the fastest
growing city over that period.
And you can watch
in this animation
as Las Vegas is growing.
And nearby, Lake
Mead is shrinking.
RANDY SARGENT: Watching
the millions of people
come to the site, watching
the ways it's being used,
I could not be happier.
REBECCA MOORE: In the first
few days of the release,
we had more than three million
people around the world
come and view it.
Time Magazine published
a huge feature online
and in print on what
are the phenomena
that you could see
really and grasp
for the first time in
this time lapse Earth.
RANDY SARGENT: Going back
into the history of Landsat
and looking at how the
Earth looked from space,
it's just the tip
of the iceberg.
If you look at what Earth
Engine was truly built to do,
it was built to also
provide analysis
on top of this
historical imagery.
What can we quantify what's
happening to the planet?
What are the trends?
The sort of information
that comes from that,
we need to also make
that interesting, useful,
explorable, usable by people
in the policy community,
usable by the general public.
We need to figure
out what's happening
to the Earth over time.
But we also need to be able
to communicate and understand
that.
REBECCA MOORE: This first
timelapse was a imagery,
but now we could do timelapses
of derived information.
In other words, we're turning
those pixels into knowledge.
And now, let's show
the timelapses of that.
RANDY SARGENT: Being
able to take ideas
and then scale them to
real and pressing problems,
scale them not only
to huge sets of data,
like the entire planet in this
case, but then take the results
and bring those out to everyone
on the planet, something
that we could not do
at Carnegie Mellon.
REBECCA MOORE: Take something,
like the Landsat satellite
catalog, it's a treasure
trove of data that has never
fired a single neuron
in a single human brain.
And this is sad.
Well now, these projects,
like this timelapse Earth,
are causing lots of neurons to
fire in lots of human brains.
RANDY SARGENT: If you're
interested to see more
about the timelapse Earth
that we worked on together,
please stay tuned for my talk.